reunited and it feels so good Mark
Ruffalo's not holding back when it comes
to Tom Holland rejoining the Marvel
Cinematic Universe the amazing he caught
up with mark on Wednesday in New York
City where he opened up about spider-man
eventually leading the Avengers I think
it's amazing
he's a great guy he's a great actor and
I had a good feeling that they would
they would work it out I mean it's it's
good so then then I was sad I just can't
even imagine after what we've all done
together like how you would separate
them mark also just on his new movie
dark waters and if there was pressure
playing the real life character of Rob
bill I you you know you have that person
you have their family you have you have
their legacy there's a there's a lot you
have to be responsible for you know
people are far more fascinating than
fiction you know and and the truth is
always way more complex and nuanced and
dialectical in its nature than than
fiction and so it's exciting to play
real people I see it as reportage I see
it as a kind of journalism you know
brutal and radical honesty and I don't
know how I did let's not forget Anne
Hathaway is also in the movie she plays
marks on-screen wife Sarah never worked
with her before but immediately like
Walter had Sympatico you know she really
understood it she understood the cost of
it and she gave her an amazing
performance
speaking of Anne what did Rob's wife
think about the casting choice she loved
it and and she thought that you know
miss Hathaway did a fantastic job and it
was when she came down also and met with
Sarah and they spent some time together
and I think she did a terrific job and
capturing all that Sarah had to go
through for for two decades you need to
tell me what the hell is going on
[Music]